the game chaos on Deponia delivers what
it promises Rufus the hero sets out to
save his planet to pony up he gets in a
spin has to solve a few tricky problems
and ends up falling in love as well dead
alec is the name of the Hamburg company
which developed the adventure game cast
and fisherman embarked on an adventure
of his own when he set up the company
six years ago he invested in the
adventure game genre at a time of
dwindling popularity
one thing's nestled in your mouth kashif
for us it's about telling a story that's
why we opted to make adventure games but
we relied on our guts people said the
trend was over but it wasn't people said
the adventure game genre was dead but we
knew that there were a lot of potential
customers we just had to find them with
the right games we've done that in a
sustainable way with a lot of our games
right now it's chaos on Deponia
allotment cast-off Deponia des Alec
places a lot of emphasis on the graphics
art directors emmonak are certain is
responsible for developing the
characters she draws them by hand
similarities with real people can't be
ruled out when drawing faces whether
angry happy or irritated she often uses
reality as a reference
i SPECT fe c morning but and appoint a
lot of me in Deponia i worked on almost
all the characters in a sense you always
for a bit of yourself when you draw the
figures it goes into the facial
expressions the postures and gestures hi
unka me make on the vassals of the spot
a few strong humidifying the third part
of the Deponia series is under
development illustrator phobias or Bell
is working on the backgrounds once the
scenery is ready the figures are
transposed onto it and animated it's
similar to classic movie animation a
team can spend a year producing a game
35 developers graphic artists and
animators worked on the whole deponia
series assists in yellow after the
success of the first part the developers
set out to make the following episodes
even more accessible a lot has changed
since their first game ednor escapes was
about a girl falsely locked up in a
mental asylum graphics and characters
have become more sophisticated since
then about 10 years and good as
adventure Wow I find a good adventure
game has to be a good mix of everything
dialogue fancy you before and carefully
crafted animations una background the
background has to be covered it should
keep you occupied our animations aren't
the most elaborate but we do a lot of
things people like wine bar Justin
delighted over form dadali faced a
varied batch of competitors at this
year's German computer gaming prize in
Jack Queen in the fire within the
frankfurt-based company dec13 sent
players on a treasure hunt then the
military simulation shooter game spec
ops
the entertainment software industry runs
a regulatory panel which checks games
and gives them an age rating that covers
1,300 games a year depends diva moment
items people we're seeing in the game
sector at the moment is a trend toward
the shooters that means action-packed
adult games we also see a trend toward
license granting that means we're seeing
fifa games we're seeing race games sold
under license and we're seeing more and
more casual games games which test the
skill of gaming newcomers using apps or
smartphones and tablets in tablets inka
computer games are a growing industry in
Germany about one out of three people in
Germany say they play more than once a
month instead of mention man chaos on
Deponia is dead Alex most successful
game at the moment it appeals to
adolescents adults comic fans and
adventure gamers ently fernanda
govardhan Damaja fonder porneia how
matters of Deponia have understood that
the soul of a game counts for a lot you
really need great backgrounds good
characters and lots and lots of humor
and they've been doing that right for
many many years extremely she said fee
and foo Yong the cast and faithful man
and his team and now working on a new
role playing game but de Dalek is
staying faithful to the adventure genre
their next game the night of the rabbit
is due for release at the end of May
thus as entire can begin